and he charged the stage they had to
grab him he was literally a murderer he
was like a killer in a gang and I just
was [ __ ] him so then I just walked
off then they had the kid went back up
he goes I told you this [ __ ]
they bring these [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that and he started thrashing me they
were dying laughing and this big guy
walked up and he goes yo you got to go
up and defend yourself you go to battle
like I would like it was like mm all
right I gotta grab it
[Music]
[Music]
so we'll be sitting up straighter those
yeah good posture okay okay you have
your own water yes is it that's for you
oh great
that's for you this is a cool little
room yeah this I've interviewed Roy Wood
jr. here as well and Ian Edwards was the
other are we going right now we're about
to I was gonna do your intro if you're
ready let's do it all right hot breath
averse welcome back to the hot breath
podcast
I'm your host comedian Joel Byers this
is your weekly guide to comedy mastery
and today's guest this guy has lived a
life of adventure at one time living in
a three-bedroom place with 13 family
members by the age of 10 he was
habitually drinking whiskey by 13 he's
in jail where coincidentally he learned
how to be funny by 15 he's in rehab
since then he's been on a comedy journey
rising up through the comedy trenches
with comics like Dane Cook Patrice
O'Neal bill burr who we actually lived
with as well this is a guy who loves
comedy and also loves helping other
comedians which is why he's on the show
today he even has did you start riot
cast you start that with me and Rob's
France yeah okay so he actually started
a podcast network to help other
comedians get their own podcast up and
running he also has his own tour creeps
with kids he's had several comedy
specials but this is about to be a
comedy special all about comedy mastery
so please welcome to the hot breath
averse Robert Bobby Kelly everyone
Robert oh you're not [ __ ] around yeah
you actually you actually did work
yeah and research and and you you uh you
are this is like you're really trying
yeah this time I am okay
this is I in this is so funny because
most podcasts let me take these yeah you
got your earbuds just an [ __ ] like
I'm an athlete you know an athlete would
have done that what what you think no so
yeah this is really things you do mm-hmm
it's some guy you know with them you
learn how to use a zoom and a camera you
know hey we do mine you go okay and then
you didn't like dude so how was it you
know what how was what
like how Scott so you actually know your
[ __ ] well yeah I told you this is like
Inside the Actors Studio for comedians
alright and this is like I mean it like
there's and I noticed most comics when
they they have a podcast and it's just
them trying to out funny each other so I
thought how can I start a podcast one
that I want to hear that'll also stand
out from all the other comedian podcasts
and here we are well plus comedians
always loves to be interviewed yes such
we so want to tell our story oh it's
true oh you get a comedian yapping about
his life and it's so of course it shut
him the [ __ ] up well we love ourselves
is what it is we love to be the center
of attention
well comics though it's that we're
always funny we are always busting balls
or trying to find the funny so when
somebody actually asks us to be serious
about our lives mm well we've been
waiting for that moment forever because
that's where all of it lies anyways
exactly well we're just little actors
yeah musicians want to be comedians
comics want to be actors we want to know
we want to just be up there and you know
accepting an award an accommodation so I
just want to thank all the people that
helped me get here just recognition that
placement that's why social media is so
[ __ ] fantastic for comedians because
they can finally just be famous and not
even be famous mm-hmm you don't even but
you took you were serious about acting
though you actually like stopped comedy
for a second right and jump tried to
make that your career first I stopped I
stopped for two years when I when I
started in Boston
I took an acting class from the sky
Peter Kelly and he was he was just he
was one that he's just got he's one of
those guys you know that has it as far
as teaching goes mm-hmm he was just an
amazing teacher and I took a small class
with him by accident I was supposed to
be in this other lady's class at this
casting agent
and he walked in he's like I need
another person and I just immediately
just shot my hand up and he was like
let's go and I I want up in his class by
accident and I remember the first thing
he said he goes okay my first question
before you do any of this is who wants
to be famous and who wants to be good
and he goes and there's no wrong answer
he was either answer is perfectly fine I
don't want you to think there's a right
or wrong answer and some people said
famous music okay got it
just to know where you're at and of
course most people like I want to be
good you know but you can be both - you
don't I mean some people you can be both
I think that's the value of social media
for comedians though because now more
than ever like I feel like we all start
because we're like well I'm the chosen
one and I was meant to rise up and be
the best comedian to ever breathe and
then now it's like or I can just create
a successful sustainable career that I
have a comfortable house and a
comfortable living and it doesn't have
to be super stardom anymore
there's comics that are lucky and
they're called famous mmm [ __ ] they're
just lucky the right time the right
place whatever the right situation I
mean you can say are they better than
anybody else I don't know I know a lot
of guys in Boston Massachusetts that are
in their 60s and 70s that are the
funniest guys I've ever heard and you
don't even know who the [ __ ] they are
mm-hmm is that luck or you know
certainly not you know Talent because
they have the talent they're [ __ ]
hilarious so y-you know it's just some
people are very lucky and there is luck
in this business and hopefully you get
some of it you know I've had some of it
I all my friends have had some of it it
goes away but if you have the ability
there was one thing when I started
acting in Boston I booked this movie
this this kid he was a I think it wasn't
be you is it being a film school or some
and it was his
you know his last what do they call that
his thesis their thesis yeah this film
was his thesis and there was a mafia
film and I worked at a Italian
restaurant in the North End of Boston so
who I remember we the guy that they
booked to and play the mall mob guy was
uh he booked it and then he was he was
gay but when he booked it he was very
Italian and then when we were doing the
first rehearsal he decided to be gay
like a like a it was and he was like you
took my money I think it was it what are
you doing
they say I have to I have to it's a seed
that I plant it has to grow up just
trust me trust me
music I'm filming in four days I can't
[ __ ] trust you do you if you audition
like a mob guy now you're acting you
know a little effeminate it's so he kept
doing it we rehearsed for like two hours
at the end he was just like you took my
money and he was like dude I don't he's
freaking out I don't know what to do
yeah and I was like I know some people
so I took him to my rack called my
friend Steven Giorgio who's one of the
managers kind of a wise guy
Wow let me say that but let's put this
way I took him down the north end this
little Asian guy hate hood the director
and writer of the film and Steven walks
up and he's in a track suit with gazelle
diamond glasses and he walks up to one
group of old Italian man talks he's like
I'll be with you in a minute then he
walks over to another group of the tank
guys one more second then he walks over
to another group of Italian guys
whispers some stuff and then he walks
out out to us he goes I'm in more
Huddle's than an NFL quarterback he goes
he grabs kidding I'll do the movie but
not for you for Bobby you already agreed
to do it wasn't even asked and he wound
up doing it and I remember he brought
like real guns he was like you need some
real gun house it was the best I
remember he brought him in to audition
you called me up then I goes Bobby I
don't do lines I can't remember nothing
course so I said don't worry about
you'll be fine we're gonna just know a
couple of them and then we'll
so we bring him into the thing to
audition same places the other guy that
was the you know the gay guy was the mob
guy a week ago or a couple days ago
whatever and he goes so he had he goes
so I come in I go hey I'm sorry and goes
you took my money you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
and he goes what da [ __ ] is right he
snaps and he grabs me so I was banging
my head off the desk
you took my [ __ ] money [ __ ] and
he throws me across the room and I slide
into all the chairs and I smash into the
wall and Eric the director was like
that's it I was like no no it really hit
me and really threw me Stephen I'm like
you can't I can't hit people I have a
concussion can't ya you can't hurt he's
like a Barbie I'm sorry I just got into
it no I'm gonna get into it you're right
that was the first movie I did and from
there
I got another movie which is what people
think like acting in this business it's
like I said it's luck it's it's favors
it's friends doing something so it's
it's like you know it I think that's me
is that my pocket was it is it you know
not put it on vibrate but that that is
what I've heard and you know I've almost
done 200 of these episodes and a common
probably the most common theme is like
all most of your opportunities are gonna
come from people you know it's just it's
it's friends mm-hmm it's friends it's
people that know you from something that
will give you something it's you know
that movie led to another movie led to a
play mmm and and I was out of comedy for
over a year and a half and you know
meanwhile Patrice Billy Byrd Dane Cook
Bob Marley Gary Gulman we're all doing
stand-up every night so I was kind of
left behind a couple years and what
brought you back into it everything was
done you know the play was done mm-hmm
I did the play like an off-broadway play
and it didn't go went for a month or so
and then I went back to comedy but I you
know when you're a comic it's like when
you get back up on stage but here's a
funny part I went back and I was so far
behind that I couldn't get on I think
people that I thought sucked were ahead
of me and I remember sitting there going
you know what [ __ ] this I think I was
talking to Dana I was in the back and I
was like I'm out [ __ ] this this piece of
shits on right now
I gotta [ __ ] what I'm sitting here do
just hang out you'll you'll you know
you'll get you just hang just gonna be
here just get a hang on I'm gonna [ __ ]
and right then that's when noxee Kevin
Knox is one of the greatest comics ever
in Boston who's passed away now
he came up he's gonna do five minutes I
was like yeah and I went up and killed
and from there he would put me on every
week from that I started getting up over
here and then I started getting up now
okay he's legit and that's what young we
all want somebody to tell us we're good
enough to keep doing it we all want
someone one of the guys to go you're
good all's it is is showing up hmm all's
it is is being there and having the
desire to be funny that's all it is
getting on stage and being there that's
it because if you're not there you're
not gonna be there when they go you want
to go on when they need somebody and if
you're not doing it all the time you're
not gonna get better how often were you
going up like what is because we're this
is this is Dane Cook this is Bill burr
that like you're Gary Gulman I know you
were waiting tables with at one time
like you're you're with these superstars
of comedy like in the grind mode of
comedy before you're anything before
there's opportunities like we wouldn't
know what uh cyl we didn't know
opportunities back then no no no we
weren't thinking about [ __ ] TV we
weren't thinking about we weren't
thinking about any of that [ __ ]
everybody want you know that's the one
thing we were just thinking about
getting on stage and being funny that's
all we were thinking about where are we
getting on stage to my stage time where
are we getting on stage
it wasn't about fire year from now
wasn't about
any of it we did whatever we had to do
job wise so that we could go and be on
stage that night and do stand-up and
then hang out for hours and make each
other laugh mm-hmm the that was the that
was it that was fine that was enough how
often were you're on stage every night
every night
every night we could get on we were run
we were running from you know driving a
half hour to get on stage do five
minutes and then flying to another club
a half hour way to try to get on stage
maybe not even get on stage we're
running back and forth as much as we can
to get on stage and we were going on
stage with some of the best comics in
the world like some of the funniest
people ever we're hosting and on the
show with you so you're following just
murderers people say why I Boston comics
good because we had to be the stakes
were higher we weren't in front of
[ __ ] crowds that were you know our
friends or you know nice it was a bunch
of Boston [ __ ] who paid money to laugh
and then you have Steve Sweeney and
Kevin Knox and Don Gavin and Joe and
Eddie and all these guys on the show too
so be funnier
be gone mmm there was no time to not
have your [ __ ] together mm-hmm and have
the confidence to get on that stage and
and and so yeah it was it was crazy we
went on a lot man but we we cared more
about I think that and we cared about
the hang the hang after was the [ __ ] you
know sitting in front of the club going
to Dominic's getting a slice and making
each other laugh was you know just as
important as cuz that's where your funny
is that's why if you look at all those
guys where none of us are alike on stage
we have similarities but we're all very
different because we learned how to be
funny as ourselves
it's like we're off stage being in front
for being funny making each other laugh
you know in front of Dominique's pizza
place at 1:00 in the morning so we were
bringing that up on stage we weren't
watching TV we didn't watch other
[ __ ] comics we didn't sit there in
YouTube comics for hours or watch
late-night sets and oh that's how you do
it we didn't do that [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
want to watch other common [ __ ] you I'm
a comic get on let me get on that
[ __ ] stage and tear it up I'm gonna
go do me whatever that is so you know
that's why when you see us even back
then we came to New York we were all
different yeah all different styles of
comedy we would kind of create in our
own thing up there because we were
taking what we were off stage and
bringing it on stage so I think that's I
mean I like that are you listening
like in conversation whenever you get a
laugh or you like okay let me make note
of that to take on the stage or it's you
focus on how you're saying things like
how do you get that translation like
Utah I just talking to Quinn upstairs
bitching about somebody somebody on
[ __ ] Twitter on Instagram gave this
famous comic three prayer hands gave me
two prayers I mean you have another
comic you prance and I didn't get any
prayer it's like you [ __ ]
you're grown man I'm a grown man but
it's like why didn't I get [ __ ] three
print why the [ __ ] you letting us know
how important we are
what the [ __ ] and he's like if you don't
do that on stage ah I'll never talk to
you again it's like wow sorry yeah man
it's I mean look I I have no problem I
have no problem with people who learn to
be funny I don't give a [ __ ] but you're
not gonna make me laugh sitting down I'm
not gonna go have [ __ ] coffee with ya
mm-hmm I'm not gonna have a slice of
pizza with you and [ __ ] bust balls
cuz you're not funny you can be funny
great go ahead I mean I like funny
[ __ ] people
you know the people I hang out with the
people I know make me laugh offstage and
then they go onstage and do stand-up you
know but but they they're able to be
themselves onstage as much as they are
off
which I guess takes time but it's starts
with an awareness offstage first I just
think now comedy has changed now you can
watch seventy [ __ ] hours of your
favorite comic on YouTube mm-hmm you can
sit there and just mimic what that is
you know it's just I mean it's just an
illusion it's it's misdirection
you know it's blah blah blah and they're
blah blah blah blah mm-hmm that's all it
is it's tempo but then I you know I know
guys you're going like you know like
Patrice we just go onstage and be him
people walk out of the room my god you
know Billy Bern same thing Jim Norton is
just diabolical on stage he's like why
would you even [ __ ] talk about that
and it's like because it's him you know
that's his thing so he is offstage
those are those are the comics that it's
I mean it's not the fast road but it's
like it seems to be the long but
sustainable Road is like the comics like
you're saying like a Jim Norton like
Bill burr Patrice these guys were always
focused on just being authentic on stage
and over time let focused on it we just
were just were like diagnose it right
okay not like we could go home and there
was no YouTube there was no [ __ ]
Comedy Central you know I was just
starting mm-hmm you don't I mean the
comedy saturation hadn't it happened but
it was on like you know evening at the
improv and comedy starlight and you know
stand up stand up all those does that
show where everybody did like seven
minutes of clean material you know I
mean it's just tight and just yeah and
that was a big thing when I was coming
up look you got to have seven minutes of
clean material but we're we all came up
with like go [ __ ] yourself none of us
want to be on that horse [ __ ]
none of us want to do evening at the
[ __ ] improv who the [ __ ] wants to do
that hey how are you [ __ ] off watch that
show now it doesn't hold up you know so
what can comics do now - like you said
comedies changing what change then you
know III I don't know I think I mean
look what's the last special you saw
that was like wow didn't even take you
that long right true when you asked us
you know prior live in concert Eddie
Murphy raw Eddie Murphy delirious George
Karl I mean you don't I'm saying mm-hmm
now there's so much [ __ ] out there
that's what was going through my head
you saw so many things that you don't
know what the [ __ ] to pick when you're
nervous to tell me like is this a good
one
exactly don't know mmm-hmm nobody knows
the greats I mean yes chappal right / I
guess and you know maybe Ellen you know
there's so much stuff out there right
now it's hard to you know but I think
somebody's gonna do it somebody's gonna
pop out somebody's gonna have something
where we're gonna go what the [ __ ] is
that
mm-hmm usually in comedy when it gets
saturated somebody just takes a left and
does something different you know what
do you think that would be like we are
stand-up or AR somebody's gonna just say
[ __ ] you and talk about [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and and you're gonna have to deal with
it
mm-hmm not care you know Eddie Murphy
and delirious came out and said [ __ ] and
got [ __ ] from everybody you know and
then he just went up and raw and talked
about it there's a real gay guy on top
of the Congo we I mean you [ __ ] yeah you
don't I mean mm-hmm
I mean it's just you know I think
something like that will happen you know
I know maybe not maybe this is just what
it is now maybe comedy is just little
pockets of these people like this and
those people like that and the masses
you know like the
this mm-hmm I have no [ __ ] clue dude
what was it about Dane that erupted what
was his luck what was that sparks just
dude you know he was clean yet edgy
good-looking you know young energetic
you know what I mean he he I mean people
talk about giving oh so funny people
like you gotta give you you put your
stuff on Instagram I'm gonna give it
away
Dane did that [ __ ] back with Napster mmm
gave his whole album way on Napster it
was him
people weren't stealing it he stole it
and gave it away and made it look like
people then people just stealing his
stuff but they were sharing it
he knew back then you need people to
share your [ __ ] get them into you first
and then you can charge them later
mm-hmm
and that's kind of coming back now with
like Andrew Schultz exactly these guys
are like just [ __ ] it give it away you
know because the model was a couple
years ago or five years ago you work
your ass off Comedy Central or one of
these people give you a special you do
an hour and then you're in now you can
now you can sell out rooms or theater
small theaters and build from there
that's gone nobody knows why anybody
gets us people have specials you like
what that's not even stand up that's not
that's a story like yeah that's a TED
talk I don't even know what the [ __ ]
that is I didn't laugh for [ __ ] three
minutes
I didn't [ __ ] and when I did laugh I
just went huh
that's not stand up when it was every 30
seconds stepping on someone's neck [ __ ]
you I'm making you laugh I have people
come up to me after my show dude you
made me laugh the whole time
what there yeah there what the [ __ ] what
did you just see well I shark comic
couple weeks ago I you know I laughed
but it wasn't the whole time it was you
know all right well I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is you see that that's
where it's changed also is it's more
just like it's not funny but it's it's
ironically not funny one-man show
yeah comedy is you know it's it's a
weird now you know like it if you you
know you want a safe place to do your
comedy it's like the comedy club is the
safe space we're saying terrible [ __ ]
mm-hmm so you don't have to mmm we're
literally saying all the things that you
think racist sexist scary [ __ ] up
hatred we're discussing that stuff so
you can laugh at yourself and go good
I'm not I'm not I'm not a racist I'm
just an [ __ ]
he thinks that that's funny all right
and you don't have to you know you know
go to work and say you're not in the
jobs that you know the things saying and
it's a it's a pressure valve that we
release through laughter so you can go
it's not that that you know what it's
he's [ __ ] right he's right that is
[ __ ] up it's not right it's
politically incorrect but that's
absolutely true and funny and I laughed
at it so you know okay all right it's
sometimes they don't laugh and what is
what is your like I always ask comics
like a story of getting booed on stage
or just like the most epic bomb they've
had in their career which what stands
out to you now you know usually it's
funny usually people who boo now usually
one boo and it's usually you said
something they didn't like it's a no
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ] child
oh you didn't hear you got offended I
think you just laughed at five minutes
of [ __ ] I mean making fun of this guy's
face you fine with that sure he wasn't
I'm sure deep down somewhere he was like
this hurts
but he was laughing at it but you don't
really get booed anymore there's got to
be some bombs you've had I've had bombs
but I mean I deserve them you know
shouldn't have been there you know
outdoor [ __ ] yeah I don't really bomb
any more I do good oh yeah this is like
in the early days when you're like still
trying to figure it out
yeah I've bombed the wood I mean the
worst most I mean I don't mind I've had
big bombs but the most terrifying bomb I
had was in Buffalo outside of Buffalo I
did an all-black underground nightclub
yes and I was you know I did I did black
rooms all the time in New York and I
loved just all black crowds yeah I did
yeah I do him in Atlanta all the time
yeah you're funny you're funny exactly
they do not not want to laugh they want
to laugh but I do stink you'll know
about it yep but if you're funny there's
no better and it doesn't matter what you
say if it's funny to laugh mm-hmm
and I remember I just was so cocky I I
took the train up there and I'm oh the
guy that picked me up was a legitimate
Tim like he was a pimp
he had a big medallion and he gave me a
big bucket of chicken wings and I was
like I was just sitting in the car like
thirty wings in a bucket and this big
SUV and he said yeah most comics we get
they love those I was like okay I really
want wings right now you know and he
dropped me off at the hotel and there's
Emma this other guy knocked on the door
big [ __ ] he came in I'm here to
pay you and he counted out the cash
twenty-five hundred bucks cash on the
bed he was counted I go I trust you goes
counted I was like okay okay and one two
and I remember I did this gig and the
kid that went up before me was a local
emcee he hated it that I was there he
was a gill using this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and you're not headlining me and I
he was mad he would not buried me I went
up and bombed I mean and this guy from
the back said something and I started
thrashing him and I was getting laughs
my God look at you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] toothpick [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
wife beater on go [ __ ] is and he charged
the stage they had to grab him he was
literally a murderer he was like a
killer in a gang and I just was [ __ ]
him so then I just walked off then they
had the kid went back up he goes I told
you this [ __ ] they bring these
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that is
trashing me they were dying laughing now
this big guy walked up and he goes yo
you got to go up and defend yourself you
go to battle like I would like it was
like mm all right you know like I
grabbed it
no I'm good he goes no you have no
choice you've got to go defend use and
he handed me a mic and as I'm walking up
this kid was thrashing me
he's ignite man you do this to me Mom it
was a nightmare she said it all stopped
i sat over in this room and the guy
walked up because y'all be with you in a
minute
he was mad he was mad that he had paint
pay me all this money and I'm sitting
there for two and a half hours I turned
into a nightclub so two and a half hours
I'm just sitting in this little corner
finally I just went to this woman who
was dating this guy or whatever and I
said can I go please my shootings on
baby all right Lee and this guy walked
over and he goes yo through this key to
it like a 14 year old kid he's a little
cousin
you drive this [ __ ] home so this
little kid drove me home and this big I
don't care if we get pulled over I know
you don't have a license he got me back
the hotel I got my money I went to the
train station
I hid between a soda machine and a
vending machine until the train came and
like 6:30 in the morning oh and I just
find I got by out of there she [ __ ]
terrifying twenty five hundred cash 25
minute cash in my sock oh my waiting for
somebody to just I was just waiting for
a couple cars to pull up yo I'm gonna
need that money back I was like yeah see
you later
I spent 20 on a coke and a bag of nachos
yeah it was bad how long into your
career was that jeez man that had to be
the early that'd be the late too late
night in 1998-99 mm maybe mm something
around there you know it was it was it
was I was cocky enough to think I could
do anything and it really brought me
back down to earth so now if it's a
certain gig I'm just like now I'm good
right yeah but now I have the ability to
I have the ability to go up and just of
course I can read the room and be like
what's up and if I start to bomb you
know I bomb now in front of like
you know uptight white rooms because
they're the ones who are [ __ ] offended
at [ __ ] I feel like at your level it's
the audience bombing like you're capable
of yours versed enough in stand-up
comedy to where it's like no I know what
I'm doing this this is how it's done
um yeah to some extent but I still fall
victim to the comic ego still yeah I
mean we all have the comic ego right
we're like you know I can do this
of course you know I can get them I got
you know but I always do good you know
but sometimes good is worse than bombing
sometimes a nice bomb is a better story
than how'd you do good sufficient might
again right that's just the worst nice
to me it's like you want I [ __ ]
killed right you want to be able to just
murder I'm a laugh [ __ ] for sure yeah I
need them all yeah but sometimes you
don't it's always the worst me and
Patrice used to do shows together and
we'd stand out at the end of the show
while the crowd was leaving and see who
got the most you twos come in little
mayyyyyo you're so funny and that's the
other 100 that always happens too
because in reality it doesn't matter
because at this stage of the game it's
not like I'm I'm not trying to make it
I've already made it now maybe not in
the standards of other you know well
you're not you don't have a bazillion
dollars like some comics and yeah but
I'm fine I got a house I got a kid you
know I'm you know I'm working this club
you know I'm working the Laughing Skull
the lavish girls not an easy Club to get
into it's not a cliff they don't just
let anybody headline here right yeah so
it's you know it's like okay I can I can
i I only work clubs I like now I don't
work clubs I don't like I say no I don't
I say no mm-hmm you know unless they
give me a shitload of money but there's
a certain thing or so as far as making
it that's that to be able to say no
you know not be somewhere I don't want
to be doing something for somebody I
don't want to do being taken advantage
of I mean that's a [ __ ] huge plus to
me how long did it take you to get to
that point well you know here it took me
longer because I had more
responsibilities I mean it was just me
in a one-bedroom I could have done it
forever true you know once you get it
hot you know a house in a mortgage in
the family and blah blah blah
it's like certain gives you like I gotta
take this gig I gotta go take the hit
mm-hmm but then there's a point where
you're like um I just can't do it
anymore because my soul hurts too much
you know and you're I'm not funny here
this isn't what this isn't about funny
this is about selling chicken wings or
some [ __ ] and nobody hear can't cares
about stand-up comedy so I love the
Comedy Cellar they care so much about
the comics performing at their [ __ ]
peak level you know that that you can't
talk you can't yell out there is no
check spot there is no [ __ ] you don't
have your phone they make you put it in
a bag okay if you see if you take if
you're seeing with the phone you're
immediately tossed you're not asked to
put it away you're gone that's saying
our comics are [ __ ] very important
and them being comfortable is very
important for them to perform at the
best level they can possibly perform at
and it's so true and and I work clubs
that do that now you know so I'm happy
about that I mean look at some clubs
that I work like side splitters in Tampa
I mean it's a [ __ ] it's like the Wild
West but I think kind of like that I
love those [ __ ] fans down there
mmm-hmm you know cuz they're [ __ ]
crazy but you have fans you know like
it's people come to see you now yeah but
I'm one of those guys who had a turnover
turnover every single Rock on the beach
looking for them oh really how did I
find them you still have to you know I
have to [ __ ] find my fans I have to
get them some people have just given
fans you know
some comics that are literally just
given a fan base and it's just like wow
I've been [ __ ] for 20-something years
building a fan base of people who like
my [ __ ] and and that's that's who they
aren't I I'm they're the best they come
and see me five six times yeah wow
that's great
how can comics start to build a fan base
what kind of tips do you have for that
well I don't know man it's you know it's
it's weird it's like you know you can
get a mailing list you can sit outside
and you know get ready to sign up on
your mailing lists and you know you can
do all the [ __ ] I just don't know I
don't know man I don't know okay some
people get one little tiny show on this
whatever network and they're famous you
know I mean looking look at girl code a
few years ago five years ago those girls
were like you know openers MCS mm-hmm at
comedy clubs and they did a little
[ __ ] it show on on vh1 and beak it
was a MTV right yeah didn't watch TV and
and they're selling out theaters you
know something interesting I heard you
say was not doing things for the outcome
but doing them for the sake of like just
doing something well so not having
almost expectations maybe well listen
like I said before some people want to
be famous mmm some people want to be
good you know I think if you worry about
just trying to be good you have no
expectations therefore you have
everything you need
yes mmm you know I don't have to worry
about the show tonight
I don't have to worry about selling it
out as much as I have to worry about
what am I gonna do what am I gonna talk
about what do i what do I want to talk
about tonight what am i doing
so that I can feel good when I come
offstage you know and the fans or the
success will come from that
you never know when you're gonna be
famous you never know when that lucky
thing is gonna happen you know look I
was on HBO for nine weeks you know I
thought I was gonna I thought I was
gonna buy a Ferrari I thought I was
gonna be living in that bet you know
what I mean mmm didn't happen you know
yet you know some somebody does a little
shitty MTV talking-head thing and
they're [ __ ] millionaires who the
[ __ ] knows do you think that person saw
me on HBO is like wow and then all of a
sudden I'm looking at them going holy
[ __ ] right I mean that you can't really
there's no rhyme or reason to that [ __ ]
the fastest horse doesn't win the race
ever in this business so you can't look
at that you can't go on Instagram and
look at people's you know Fame because
it's not real it's not stoned it's not a
foundation it's just this thing I showed
out a show yeah but there was only it
was a 20 cedar as a headliner what the
[ __ ] I didn't I didn't sell out I only
had 20 people at my show yeah you're the
same amount of people mmm this is his
only fit 20 people and it was in
Brooklyn at a coffee shop sold-out show
man thanks for showing up and you're
like what the [ __ ] Mike recall your
manager I'm [ __ ] you better do
something like resume it dude
I just sold I showed 300 tickets some
yeah I'm gonna theater what the [ __ ]
shut up mm-hmm you know you can't look
at anybody else's success you can't you
can't
it's the heart you will you can't you
know and I always I always knew this you
know talent isn't afraid of talent you
know it's it's you know I hang out with
the funniest people in the world and
we're never really in competition with
each other
you know what I mean I never sit down
with bill burr and go - you're doing so
better than me well it's we just we know
the business we understand it you know
I'm funny he's funny you know and when
we sit down and hang out we just have
fun it's a good time it's yeah I mean
that [ __ ] is never in our mind we never
think about that [ __ ] I never sit there
and talk about the biz how but early
earlier on in your careers were there
moments where you guys are sitting
around just like man I just don't even
know like is quitting is this gonna work
like look yes
candidly at certain times when you were
like trying to get something like I'm
this close to getting a TV show and I
really want it and you're like [ __ ] come
on you know I remember you know we've
all had those moments I'd really want to
get this man I hate I need and I need
this little bump - you know - I need
this you know mm-hmm
but in reality it's all gonna happen no
matter what you do you know it's just
it's it why were you there excuse me why
were you there that day you know what I
mean why were you in LA that day and you
went up on that show and that guy saw
you you know why did a billy Berger get
booed at Penn and Philly mm-hmm and went
off in the crowd and there was producers
there from a thing and they so why were
they there why did he get booed how did
it how did he know - how to be funny and
smash them back why did he just go [ __ ]
you and walk off if you would [ __ ] you
and walked off a lot of things would
have been different in his life you know
yeah but he still would have made it
Bert would have still made it because
there's nobody who works harder than
that guy you know it's that 10,000 hour
thing rings true all the time really yes
you know
what would he do like what you mean no
one works hard on him what is well he
would sit down with the computer all day
and write jokes and look at the TV and
[ __ ] and moan about things and that's
how he came up with his thing mm-hmm
take what he does talking to us and
bring it up on stage and but he would do
the work you know what I mean I never
saw producing the notepad never saw him
with a pen
write something down he would just think
about some call up me call up Keith call
up bill and just start talking about it
this [ __ ] and then he would make
you laugh and keep it and then blend
then go onstage and be like I ever see
these bit and then all of a sudden
there's the buck there's the [ __ ]
amazing bit that he just came up Wow you
know so you know Colin Quinn writes his
face off all day you know Colin Quinn
takes a subject and just does it his way
it's crazy you know it's crazy comedy is
a [ __ ] sick drug man it's really it's
the best no it is it is great but it is
you know it's a [ __ ] it's just sick
it's a weird it's like why you know you
can't get away from it it's like you
know it's like it's like having a
superhero power that you don't want
sometimes you know just wanna you should
want to be able to look at something
normal yeah you know and just not you
know [ __ ] like be Mike my wife was
just normal you know what I mean you
know but that makes it more fun when you
can look at you know it life through
that lens I mean it always makes it more
interesting as opposed to oh it doesn't
make it more fun our lives are [ __ ]
crazy
we rip everything apart you can't take
anything for face value we don't trust
anybody or anything everything that
comes across our plate we're analyzing
and [ __ ] shredding up to see if
there's any well why the [ __ ] did you do
that why would she say this what the
[ __ ] is that
look why would you do that oh that's
stupid that's hilarious [ __ ] him [ __ ]
her I mean all day long we'll never [ __ ]
anything going nice
good you know life's good life is we're
so blessed yep nice to have air have the
day we should go take a walk you say
that to a common [ __ ] walking with
you you weirdo
walk that's why talking to comics is the
best is just because there's that
shorthand of like we both know none of
this matters it's like we always have an
analytical I'm sure at the cellar table
like you're getting roasted until you go
like throw away some of your clothes
like just having that rapport with other
people that's a salad tables dead though
dude it's gone
I mean with you guys though yeah we're
there but we're [ __ ] dead to it I mean
you got us is dead literally true one
Ohio had a stroke the other one had a
heart attack I'm probably gonna have
both very soon I mean you think so
I mean working on it we don't you know
the table now is so funny I always say
to be funny at the table it would be
funny if busting balls more important
than being able to smash somebody more
important than coming up with a good
line about some of these jeans or face
or act you have to be able to take the
hit mmm when somebody says something
[ __ ] terrible about you you have to be
able to go there alright that was a good
one that's true
all right you're right I you know and I
feel like younger comics don't do that
they go well that's not true ain't no
dude what joking you know say that yeah
what yeah yeah yeah you get [ __ ] you
get way to get [ __ ] a thousand
followers you [ __ ] loser I have a
thousand in there the great followers
there I take my thousand over yeah oh
you suck that's not sure I have 1200 I
know it doesn't matter I feel like not
all of them but I even the table
sometimes you have to stick to taking a
[ __ ] hit being able to take a beating
if you can't take it then it's not fun
to the people doing it right as we only
[ __ ] with people we care about really
you know I don't make fun if you showed
up at the table we might trash a little
bit but I wouldn't sit there and smash
you as much as I would smash Norton
right oh yeah yeah yeah look Voss you
know yeah I mean he was just on here and
like half the time he was just like
roasting everything yeah it was just the
bosses just you know him and his wife
was clear funniest people on the planet
you know they just they're always going
for funny I mean they always just say
the most meanest [ __ ] ever and it's just
they're trying to be funny and it's just
funny you know trying to make each other
laugh is where I think comics comedy
starts trying to make other funny people
laugh is where it comics live cuz if I
don't laugh at it is it really funny
mm-hmm I don't know
I call clone Quinn every day or Keith
and those guys just to [ __ ] laugh
because I want to laugh too you know I
don't just be up there make it a bunch
of [ __ ] people laughter I think I
need to do that more I kind of insulate
myself and I'm not I'll go to a show but
I don't really like hang out much I'm
more of like all right let me get to
this setting in this set I'm not I don't
really like do what you said pay
attention to how I'm being funny around
other funny people and really valuing I
don't know I don't even know if that
exists anymore you know I might be a
dying thing with us I don't know this
sounds like comedians should bring it
back then well I don't know maybe
comedies evolving into something else
okay your comics talking about how to
make their angstrom better how to get
fans how to become more popular and I
think people worry about that now you
know but even with your show you're
willing to like bring in less known
comedians and like younger comics like
there is something about you I don't
know if it's your art teacher background
or it's like you just that you want to
like you want to help younger comics
well that yeah I mean that's on my
podcast
I've always bring younger comics on or
when I went to shows and and then as
soon as those younger comics make it
they'd never talk to me again
ha ha ha so what happened with Dane is
that what everyone Dame's ain't no me
and Dean came up together yeah you're an
improv group together yeah no me no like
you know I mean I think younger comics
feel like Dan Soder and Jo and Lewis and
you know that was my that was my crew I
had my crew with my my contemporaries
but those guys Joe DeRosa they became my
crew too cuz that was always a couple
years behind everybody like Bill and
mm-hmm Patrice I like I said I took off
for a little bit so I was like always a
couple steps behind them but you know I
like having young comics on the next
[ __ ] on my show you know cuz I
like to laugh - man I like these young
guys you know they they're you know I
remember when I first had Joe list on or
even naper GATS II would just sit on my
show his little [ __ ] stupid doll eyes
you be like oh this ain't you I'm sudden
you just say the most funny mean thing
ever no it's like a sniper boom anybody
like the [ __ ] I like that you know you
know you know Stavros you know I used to
eat
he used to hang out with me not even me
on the show and in Baltimore and we just
go get [ __ ] honey pig Korean barbeque
after me and that fat [ __ ]
we're just throwing stuff our fat faces
on no no pork and kimchi and then uh you
know now look at that guy he's you know
his podcast is taking off and he's
[ __ ] huge you know
so when went and kind of landing this
plane here what is there any other
advice or like a story of some of your
contemporaries or is there anything you
can leave us with that kind of close
this out I just don't you know
most of you aren't gonna be famous like
I'm looking right at you you're not
gonna make it I mean you don't think
I'll make it I am I'm definitely making
it you will not make it was like
Chappelle or Eddie Murphy or your
there's no way like looking at my shoes
you're not gonna make it we're Voss's
like I don't want to be where bosses
know it's funny there is like there is
no advice man you just create you know
do whatever the [ __ ] you don't know what
it is dude like you don't know if
somebody is gonna see this stupid show
and be like ah dude show yeah it's a
dumb show literally cific there's no
crew there's no makeup is one light from
Home Depot you assume for h4n not even
as a 6h no not even the new ones before
what are the original yeah but the two
on the bottom the top doesn't come off
right um and it's working and I got you
here yeah I know you got me here cuz you
had Voss here and you got Voss here
because you had someone else there but
this might be your thing this might be a
huge show mm-hmm in a couple years
somebody might [ __ ] see it you never
[ __ ] know the only thing you know is
you had a desire to do it and instead of
not doing it you went and learned how to
use that dumb camera you learn how to
use the zoom you learned about light you
learned about and then you've reached
out and said hey would you and somebody
said yeah and then every now you sitting
here with me you know so I just do it
just create don't worry about the
outcome don't worry about if it's gonna
be good don't worry about if people
gonna like it
you know of course I'm busting your
balls of course making it but yeah you
never you never [ __ ] know see that's
the thing about the young comics I said
when you bust their balls what are you
talking about I'm gonna be huge shut the
[ __ ] we went this whole interview
cordial and now he's like well let me
get on my jabs in before
we in here no I was just saying much and
you need a workout I'll let you get some
swings in I think I think that's the key
to it is just just doing it just do it
do it you don't know what the [ __ ] is
gonna be Joe Rogan used to have to do to
follow him around with video cameras
because he just liked making content
he had a Joe Rogan dotnet he liked
making content that's it he had a guy
farm around and he made content and then
I'll now look at him he's bigger than
The Tonight Show you never [ __ ] know
what the [ __ ] it is so don't worry about
the outcome don't worry about how much
money you're gonna make just do it just
make contact create be creative go on
stage tell jokes write jokes get [ __ ]
like this have shows just do it all do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do you
know because life will [ __ ] filter
the [ __ ] out life for MySpace remember
that it's gone Thomas and nobody right
do you remember MySpace yeah yeah I
remember MySpace
I mean imagine that everything comes to
an end everything even Fame all that
[ __ ] comes to an end all that [ __ ]
and so you never know just [ __ ] do it
just just start just [ __ ] create
mm-hmm don't listen to your friends
calling you a [ __ ] idiot
what are you doing [ __ ] just stupid
bull guys you know don't listen to that
just do it you know just create [ __ ]
that's what I would say and don't ask
what should i do just do it yeah stop
asking people for permission to [ __ ]
be creative that's the whole opposite of
creativity you don't ask permission to
be creative you do it don't make a short
film make it with your phone mm-hmm
sound doesn't get a microphone the
lighting get some light who gives just
do it and make it and then let people
enjoy it and they'll tell you they'll
tell you you know yeah you will tell you
you made a movie with a Bill burr back
in the day and end up like getting in a
festival and all that because you just
wanted to do it just want it we were
like man why are we waiting
for people to tell us - we can be
creative why are we waiting for a
company that we don't even trust their
opinion about what's funny or good why
are we waiting for them to say make it
we put our money where our mouths were
and we made it and then I got a book
deal with Simon & Schuster an FX deal
pilot it was in the Tribeca Film
Festival from just doing it oh shut the
[ __ ] up
don't tell anybody do what you know them
just do it tell we did it's great I
loved I loved that stuff that's one of
the things I love is that me burned
duros it just made a movie and then
obviously they're so funny after
everything happened all these people
that called us up that wanted to be part
of our thing I was like what are you
talking about you want to be part of
what you want where will you join forces
why we don't need you why would after
the fact we don't need we just proves we
don't need you
mm-hmm you need us you've came up with
nothing you've done nothing you've
created nothing you put no effort into
anything and you now you're like hey
will you guys know [ __ ] you it's the
greatest power in the world man is is is
knowing that you can just do it yourself
so shoot that's a huge power so you can
just learn how to do it I mean that
camera I mean most people won't do this
because they don't want to buy that and
figure it out yeah you know I have that
show live from the shed mm-hmm I talked
about it for a long time nobody wanted
to do it I was like you know what [ __ ]
you all I just went and learned how did
they I you know we did it and then it
was like okay the people that were gonna
do it with the cameras weren't gonna do
it anymore
so I was like all right I just went and
bought the cameras and I watched video
after video how to learn how to use a
[ __ ] G a G H 5 mm-hmm and it sucked
and I did it and I learned about
lighting that I learned about sound I
watched all these videos now couple
weeks ago Billy Burke came to my house I
filmed the whole episode
myself didn't need a [ __ ] soul nobody
everything done by me editing it on my
iPad by myself because I learned about
anything I don't need anybody to tell me
I can do something I have found with
this production I've gone in and out
with I tried to work with an audio guy
and then I tried to work with a video
guy and it just it all nothing ever
lined up it just came down to you got to
do it yourself you want it done to
yourself yeah just you should just do it
I think that's the key and I wish you
stopped me earlier I just went on and on
holy [ __ ] whose good advice huh there's
good advice we could have [ __ ] I mean
just cut that down a little bit just do
yourself do it yourself that'd Mauna
Lani but that's why we're here you know
to get you on the record the end of this
I feel like this show doesn't exist so
having people of your caliber and
experience on here and being willing to
share so much information really proves
we're on the right path here I think so
and you know you're from this Atlantis
scene - I really like yeah it's great
yeah you be you comics a grit you comics
are hanging with each other doing [ __ ]
going for like even last night there was
a bunch of comics on the show and then
they they were like what you know what
they're like where you go I'm going to
another spot that's like I love that
it's like you know some of them hanging
out a little bit the other ones are
going to run to do another spot it's
like that's the [ __ ] that's that that's
a comedy community yes no which I love
you guys got a great comedy community
here and you guys really push each other
to to get on stage and perform which is
important yeah this show started out as
kind of like a time capsule of Atlanta
comedy when they had like we had ten
comics on Last Comic Standing from
Atlanta and we won it two years in a row
and I was like oh that's a cool time
capsule and now it's evolved into like
Inside the Actors Studio for comedy in
general but yet Lana is where this grew
from for sure yeah Lana's a pretty
[ __ ] hot you know and the Laughing
Skull is such a great oh my gosh
incredible yeah yo it's incredibly lucky
to have ya the people that owned that
you know that run that
if they really get it yeah they nurture
local talent to really big-time they
really care which is you know not you
know usually that it's not the case
mm-hmm you guys got a good thing here
and we got out we got Gary Gulman coming
here in September your boy the best
maybe he'll do this show
he's the bill well now he's got oh
because you're gonna get I know I did
work really good then I think it hit him
up on him probably did Robert Kelley did
it and he's gonna call me should I do it
like guys nice kid yeah do it
that's the bestest shitty business I
thought those comics help in common yeah
well first of all I've never seen you do
that's true and I don't like to
interview people until they see me
perform because what worries is like
they're like oh he's pretty good
interviewing you probably sucks at
comedy it's like I usually I feel like
you don't meet a comic till you see them
on stage and it's like I don't I like
people to have the context that I am
like a comedian first I trust joking
again before you I got so defense for
Gary don't make fun of them gets uptight
guess I'll whipped up [ __ ] are you
married I am married yeah kids I have a
dog it's not a kid you [ __ ] it's
closed no it's not not even near it dogs
gonna die in five years I hope so
lives out lives you but my wife like you
say with your wife she's like everything
like I mean she's a great motivator and
like it's just kind of like the the
foundation the anchor right that's great
yeah that's good meanness yeah tell Gary
to do you have to [ __ ] show that's
you really wanted you really know the
evolution of this is right if I get I
don't want fuss but I'll get lost that
way at least get Robert I I would take
Rabbi riddle
I want Gary Gulman how do I get Gary
Gulman a new you I've sat down she said
well just get some of his friends and
work your way up and that's what you did
so you'll have Gary yes what if I tell
them not to do it
what if I say dude don't do it I mean
you know this bit
this it all comes back around oh here we
go that's right sceeto he's like the
Dutch he doesn't get sarcasm well I went
back and forth in our interview with the
rich I went back and forth with them but
like with you I just kind of like no
I'll tell you no I don't need it I don't
need see that's just condescending and
kunti you're getting defensive now
because I'm jabbing back and now you're
like wait he's just being kunti now
you've been cut to you more Gandhi now
you're analyzing it in a real way what a
[ __ ] loser listen we both took them
personally no no I'll tell Gary to do it
I will
that's so nice a little interview I
appreciate it no problem and you've got
me coffee so III try to appease so in
the final thing the guests do if you
wouldn't mind looking in the camera
letting the world know who you are and
why they should listen to hot breath
this is Robert Kelley and you should
listen to hot breath all right Robert
Kelley thanks to being on hot breath my
man
[Music]
I breath